Another Thing Dr. Bright Is Not Allowed To
Do At The Foundation: When writing a report,
more detail is expected than "Object class:
Keter.
Special Containment Procedures: [DATA EXPUNGED].
Description: [DATA EXPUNGED]."
And inventing new security clearances just
so nobody can see what you've written is also
considered poor form.
We all know sometimes RAISA can get a little
redaction-happy, we understand the frustration,
but that’s frankly no excuse to fill your
documents with nonsense and then hide them
from us.
If you keep doing this, we’ll send Technical
Researcher Rosen after you, and we both know
that guy’s a huge jerk.
Mark our words, Dr. Bright, we are not bluffing
- even if you do claim to have Security Clearance
Level 420!